you
the staging of lung cancer refers to the
extent of the disease if you have the
most common form of lung cancer or
non-small-cell lung cancer it will be
staged according to the size of the
tumor and whether it has spread to the
lymph nodes or other organs of the body
in the occult or hidden stage cancer
cells are found in coughed up mucus or
in other lung fluids but no tumor can be
seen in the lungs stage 0 is not
considered invasive because the cancer
cells are found in the innermost lining
of the air passages but have not grown
through it stage 1a is considered
invasive cancer because the tumor has
grown through the inner lining of the
airways into the deep lung tissue when
measured the tumor is no more than 3
centimeters in diameter and has not
spread to the bronchi lymph nodes or
distant sites in stage one be the
diameter of the tumor is larger than 3
centimeters or has spread to a main
bronchus or has grown through the lung
into the inner layer of the pleura in
stage 2 a the tumor is no more than 3
centimeters across but it is spread to
nearby lymph nodes on the same side of
the chest as the tumor there are two
scenarios that can occur with stage 2b
lung cancer one where cancer cells have
not spread to nearby lymph nodes but
have invaded the chest wall diaphragm
pleura the membranes surrounding the
heart or a main bronchus in the second
scenario for stage 2b the cancer has
spread to the lymph nodes on the same
side of the chest as the tumor also the
tumor is larger than 3 centimeters
across or has grown into a main bronchus
or has grown through the lung into the
pleura in stage 3 a the tumor may be any
size and the cancer cells have spread to
the lymph nodes on the same side as the
lung tumor also the cancer may have
spread to the chest wall diaphragm
pleura the mem
brains around the heart or a main
bronchus but not the trachea in stage 3b
the tumor may be any size and has spread
to lymph nodes above the collarbone or
on the other side of the chest the
cancer may have spread to nearby
structures such as the heart major heart
vessels diaphragm chest wall trachea
esophagus breast bone or to more than
one place in the same lung in stage four
cancer has spread to other lobes of the
same lung or into the opposite lung and
has spread to other parts of the body
such as the brain liver kidneys adrenal
glands or bone